un sur deux il ya un français sur deux
qui pensent passer à côté de sa vie voit
cette idée là elle me rend malade il ya
quatre ans j'ai eu un accident de
voiture
je m'en suis sorti miraculeusement je
m'en suis pas rendu compte tout de suite
mais en fait c'était une chance
incroyable de me rendre compte de façon
très concrète de quelque chose qu'on
connaît tous et abstrait dont on devrait
se souvenir plus souvent la vie est
courte et tout peut s'arrêter très vite
alors pour moi depuis jour là hors de
question de passer à côté de ma vie hors
de question de passer une journée plus
sur cette planète à faire quelque chose
je ne semble pas utile je trouve pas du
sens quelque chose où j'ai pas
l'impression de grandir d'apprendre de
me sentir vivant tout simplement pour
moi ne pas passer à côté de sa vie c'est
essayer de faire en sorte que chaque
moment chaque journée chaque heure
chaque minute chaque seconde presque un
moment de très grande qualité pour moi
ne pas passer à côté de sa vie
concrètement en fait ça veut dire ne pas
passer à côté des opportunités qui nous
sont données qui me sont donnés de vivre
des choses incroyables
bon alors quand on a dit ça on n'a pas
dit grand chose parce qu'en fait
concrètement on sait pas comment ça se
passe comment on fait pour se lancer en
fait quand on a peur on sait pas moi
j'ai été pendant pas mal de temps tout
seul à ruminer là à me dire mais comment
on fait et en fait
la seule technique que j'ai trouvé pour
le moment doit y avoir plusieurs
c'est de sauter dans le vide alors en
fait sauter dans le vide pour moi ça
ressemble pas vraiment à ça j'ai le
vertige
j'aimerais bien mais je peux pas sauter
dans le vide pour moi ça ressemble à ça
c'est moins sexy
mon plus gros mon plus grand saut dans
le vide c'était il ya deux ans et demi
sur le quai d'un métro du moins c'est
celui que je vais vous raconter
en fait j'étais à la fin de mes études
comme peut-être certains d'entre vous
j'étais en école de commerce et je me
demandais qu'est ce que je vais faire en
fait dans les prochaines années qu'est
ce que je vais faire pour les 80 mille
heures de travail que je vais avoir à
effectuer dans ma vie qu'est ce qui va
me faire vibrer quoi qu'est ce qui va me
passionner qu'est ce qui va me faire me
lever le matin
en fait je trouvais pas grand chose il
ya des choses intéressantes mais voilà
j'étais pas jeter pas emballé en fait à
l'époque il y avait un projet un peu fou
qui me faisait vibrer l'un de mes
meilleurs amis me proposait de le
rejoindre et monter avec lui un projet
d'entreprenariat social alors à l'époque
en fait j'avais même pas de nom
l'objectif c'était d'organiser un tour
de france pour 50 jeunes à la rencontre
de pionnier pour inspirer et mettre en
action la future génération d'acteurs du
changement tout un programme très
ambitieux mais en fait tout absolument
tout est à construire
ça me faisait vibrer parce qu'en fait ça
me faisait peur j'avais peur parce que
je ne savais pas du tout à quoi allait
ressembler ni lui ni moi ni personne
d'ailleurs ça me faisait peur parce que
je savais que personne à les comprendre
pourquoi je voulais faire ça ma famille
mes amis mes parents les premiers à me
faisait peur surtout parce qu en fait j
avais absolument jamais pensé jamais je
m'étais dit que avant même la fin de mes
études
j'allais entreprendre
j'allais monter un projet lever des
fonds convaincre des partenaires
recruter des gens manager une équipe
faire sortir de terre un projet qui
n'existait pas avant
en fait ça me faisait peur mais ça me
faisait vibrer et du coup je sais pas
pourquoi un vendredi soir sur le quai de
ce métro j'allais voir un match de foot
je sais pas non plus pourquoi j'allais
voir un match de foot
en fait j'ai eu le moment que j'ai eu
l'impression que c'était un moment a pas
laissé passer que c'était maintenant ou
jamais il ya une petite voix dans ma
tête qui a dit mais joe qu'est-ce que tu
ferais en fait c'était pas peur la
réponse était claire c'était ça et du
coup sur un coup de tête
en un quart de seconde j'ai envoyé un
texto à mon pote en lui disant c'est bon
je pars avec toi je le fais
c'était trop tard c'était parti le quart
de seconde qui a suivi
en fait ça donnait ça là je faisais
vraiment un énorme saut dans le vide
alors que j'étais toujours cramponné au
siège de métro j'en ai laissé passer
quelques ça en fait depuis deux ans et
demi je suis co fondatrice de ti cats
fortes neiges
notre mission c'est de changer la
société par l'entrepreneuriat c'est
d'identifier de révéler des talents pour
les aider justement à transformer la
société par l'entrepreneuriat en deux
ans et demi on est donc une start up
social
on a dix salariés on touche près de
35000 personnes dans 160 pays
le président de la république et
quelques ministres nous connaissent et
nous sollicitent parfois on est soutenu
par certaines des plus grandes
entreprises et grand ministère français
on a remporté le google pack challenge
il ya quelques mois alors si je vous
raconte ce moment dans le métro c'est
parce qu'en fait j'avais l'impression
que c'était un moment a pas laissés
passer et des moments comme ça je suis
sûr que vous pouvez tous en vivre mais
vous en rendez peut-être pas compte
peut-être que vous les voyez pas
peut-être que vous avez peur vous avez
des doutes des questions et en fait si
j'ai la chance d'être ici
du coup j'essaie de me dire ok mais
qu'est ce qui se passe en fait à ce
moment là pour moi qu'est ce que je fais
pour justement sauter dans le vide
j'ai essayé d'identifier si petit ips le
premier c'est d'écouter ça petit doigt
alors pas celle qui vous dit en fait
c'est d'écouter sa petite voix celle qui
tel qui vous fait rêver celle qui vous
inspire c'est d'écouter les choses qui
vous passionne ou ça bouillonne en vous
moi à ce moment là à ce moment là en
fait c'était c'était les individus qui
arrive à partir d'une entreprise à
résoudre un problème de société
c'était l'éducation c'est l empowerment
c'était l'entrepreneuriat social
le deuxième type c'est d'avancer pas à
pas en fait ça sert à rien de changer du
jour au lendemain de tout mettre de côté
de tout laisser tomber ça marche pas
comme ça
donc faut trouver les petites étapes
faut avancer à son rythme
qu'est ce qui va vous faire avancer vers
ce qui vous passionne mois il ya eu
plein d'étapes différentes et des
maraudes j'ai fait un projet je
participe à un projet humanitaire j'ai
voyagé à la rencontre d'entrepreneurs
j'ai décidé de rejoindre mon pote sur ce
projet le troisième type c'est de saisir
les opportunités souvent les petits pas
ils sont devant nous mais on les voit
pas moi ça faisait des mois
mon ami proposé de le rejoindre en fait
je le voyais pas répondre à toutes ces
questions mais pas à celle là je la
voyais pas je voyais pas que c'était
déjà devant moi le quatrième sans doute
le plus important mais plus difficile le
plus contre intuitif aussi c'est
d'accepter de ce déséquilibre est
accepté qu'en fait les conditions
parfaites elles sont jamais réunis ce
sera jamais le bon moment il y aura
toujours quelque chose qui
qui marchent pas moi cette époque là
j'avais pas fini mon parcours scolaire
j'étais pas diplômés j'avais un emprunt
ce n'était pas le bon moment
en fait ce ne sera jamais le cinquième
tips
c'est une technique un peu plus vicieuse
dans laquelle j'excelle tout
particulièrement c'est de s'engager en
fait c'est de ne pas attendre c'est le
saut dans le vide dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure c'est pas attendre qu'il
ya la deuxième petite voix qui arrivent
et qui vous d'imiter sûr en fait une
fois que vous vous à vous avez annoncé
ça vous est prononcée vocalement quelque
sorte
ben c'est trop tard vous pouvez plus
faire machine arrière j'ai envoyé le
mail pour répondre si oui ou non
j'allais participer à ce stade
après je pourrai plus me poser la
question quoi et le 6 qui me tient tout
particulièrement à coeur en fait c'est
de cette donnée le meilleur c'est
d'essayer de faire en sorte que dans
chaque étape on soit à fond on va
jusqu'au bout on essaye d'être le
meilleur de donner le meilleur d'eux
d'apprendre le plus possible
en fait avec cc6 tips la petite voix qui
vous fait douter ou qui vous fait avoir
peur à certains moments ce qu'on appelle
les croyances limitantes en fête avec
ses six petits tips elle va pas
disparaître parce qu'en fait elle
disparaîtra jamais très agréable mais il
faut accepter qu'elle soit là tout le
temps en fait avec ces sites ips elle va
pas disparaître mais vous allez la
dépasser vous allez vous dépassez vous
allez faire des choses que vous pensiez
impossible il ya un an
il ya six mois il ya deux mois je
pensais impossible me retrouvais de ce
côté-là de l'événement en fait et en
fait même si un petit peu peur même si
on se dit mais qu'est ce que je pourrais
raconter ben en fait c'est exactement ça
moi que je voulais raconter c'est de
faire en sorte que quand on nous dit on
nous dit souvent oui mais n'ayez pas
peur lancez vous en fait non c'est faux
parce qu'en fait on a peur donc on sait
pas trop ce qu'il faut faire dans ces
cas là moi c'est ayez peur et surtout
lancé vous donc en fait
il ya un français sur deux qui pensent
passer à côté de sa vie si je suis pas
trop mauvaises statistiques ça fait à
peu près la moitié de cette salle en
fait j'aimerais que j'espère en tout cas
quand vous sortirez de cette pièce vous
souviendrez de ses six petites étapes et
que vous poserez la question moi je me
suis posé sur ce quai du métro
qu'est ce que je ferais si j'avais pas
peur merci